but it's been hard we still face
challenges every day
and the pain of the pandemic is real
we've lost cherished friends and family
our health care professionals and first
responders have worked night and day
saving countless lives
teachers administrators and support
staff like bus drivers and cafeteria
workers went above and beyond to get our
kids back in classrooms safely
our nevada national guard
stepped up they stepped forward to run
testing stations distribute vaccines and
care for our seniors
our small businesses had to sharpen
their pencils care for their employees
while finding new ways to keep their
doors open
families had to adapt
helping kids study working from home
trying to keep it all together
the truth is we never gave up and while
we still have a lot more work to do we
refuse to let the pandemics stop our
progress
quite simply because of you
the state of our state is resilient and
getting stronger every day nevada is on
the move
i'm so proud of our state and our people
because despite the noise we hear from
some in politics despite the
partisanship that can distract and
divide
i know that at our core we all care
about the same things
a paycheck that keeps up with the cost
of living
schools that teach
streets that are safe
businesses that thrive and create good
jobs in the government that lives within
its means
today
i'm gonna talk about how we work
together
we can get more done
to help make your life better right now
the cost of everything is rising we all
see it nevada families are getting
squeezed at the pump and at the grocery
store
child care housing and health care costs
are eating too much of a family's income
it's hard to keep ahead of bills and
save for things like college or
retirement
while i can't promise to solve the
national inflation problem inflation
problem i can promise to do everything
in my power to help families with a
rising cost of living
that starts with holding the line on
taxes since i've been governor we have
not raised one penny of new taxes on the
people of nevada not one penny and
that's also true of every proposal i'm
offering today
no new taxes
no new taxes
these issues are important to me because
i've been there i raised two incredible
daughters by myself cooking dinners they
really didn't like going to the grocery
store trying to figure out child care
raising kids isn't easy or cheap and
that was over 20 years ago things have
only gotten more expensive
so we're standing starting by investing
in child care because nevadans deserve
the opportunity to go to work knowing
their children are safe and have every
opportunity to succeed
in the last two years we strengthened
nevada ready the state pre-k program to
get high quality child care and early
education to more kids
we have invested over 200 million
dollars in child care centers to keep
staff working and facilities open
and today i'm announcing a further
investment of a hundred and sixty
million dollars to help lower costs for
parents and keep children child care
workers on the job
this investment will double the number
of families we support because i believe
every family from west wendover to north
las vegas should have access to great
child care
another big concern is the rising cost
of housing
right now we have too little supply for
a booming demand in the last decade more
than four hundred thousand people have
moved into nevada
they know what a great state this is but
we have renters and buyers at all levels
who are being squeezed out of the market
that's why we've taken steps to remedy
our housing shortage we've provided
rental assistance that helped over forty
three thousand nevadan families remain
in their homes
we helped build over two thousand three
hundred new affordable apartments just
last year
and for thousands of those families what
really matters is keeping a roof over
their head or building equity in a home
but there's more to be done
that's why today i'm announcing homing's
nevada initiative it's a 500 million
dollar commitment to lower the cost of
housing
help people stay in their homes and
create good paying jobs
the plan boosts housing construction and
home ownership opportunities
will help seniors retrofit their homes
to lower their costs improve their
property and stay where they want to be
and we're developing a new partnership
with the afl-cio
through our state infrastructure bank
to help fund new housing developments
this announcement marks the single
largest investment in housing in our
state's history
like housing i know the rising cost of
health care also poses serious strain on
many nevada families i've been working
with democrats and republicans to help
solve that problem
we went after insurance companies and
made it illegal to deny coverage for
pre-existing conditions we were one of
the first states to crack down on
surprise billing by hospitals and
medical providers
we took on medical debt collectors who
were preying on struggling families
we helped over a hundred thousand
nevadans purchase affordable health
insurance through the silver state
health exchange
and our new public health insurance
option will make quality care affordable
for even more nevadans
that's real progress but we can't let up
for instance the cost of insulin has
tripled over the last decade to nearly
three hundred dollars of aisle
life-saving cancer drugs can cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
year
that's why today i'm announcing that
nevada will join the northwest
prescription drug consortium along with
oregon and washington state by
negotiating with drug companies together
we can start holding them accountable
and get costs down
we all know health court isn't just
about costs it's about people and it's
about jobs in the coming weeks i'll be
creating a healthcare workforce
committee to build on the lessons
learned over the last two years
we must ensure that we have the nurses
technicians and doctors that we need so
nevadans can get the care that they
deserve
now i want to talk about one of my top
priorities
someone who has someone who went to
public school and is a dad of two
daughters who did the same i know how
important a great education is
that's why i've been so passionate about
getting our kids back in the classroom
during the pandemic we deployed 1.5
billion dollars in federal funds for
mask
testing mental health support and more
so we could reopen schools safely
i'm so glad for our hard grateful for
our hard working teachers our support
staff our exhausted parents and our
amazing students
we would not be where we are today
without you thank you
when i took office i promise to do
everything in my power to make sure
every child in every classroom
gets a first grade education
that's why we gave teachers their first
directly funded raise in a decade
that's why we asked educators what they
needed and directly funded eleven
thousand projects to make school rooms
buzz
why we raised the average of per pupil
funding to a new high
and i said i would do everything in my
power to help our schools i meant
everything that's why i've donated every
penny of my salary as governor directly
to our public schools almost three
hundred thousand dollars donated to more
than a hundred different schools across
our state from southside elementary
school in elko to basic high school in
henderson and i want to take a moment to
speak directly to parents and caregivers
your voices your involvement your
thoughts are an important part of great
schools i will always support strong
parent participation in making our
education system the best it can be
i really believe that the future of our
state is directly tied to the quality of
our schools
last year i worked at the legislature to
commit 200 million dollars to get our
students caught up after the pandemic
this investment is going to summer
schools tutors and other efforts to make
sure our kids are back on track and
ready to get ahead
we're also going to invest in teacher
recruitment by providing nearly four
thousand future educators with stipends
and tuition assistance to help address
the teacher shortage
finally we all know that you can't learn
on an empty stomach so i'm announcing
that we're investing federal dollars to
ensure that our schools can provide free
lunch for all students across the state
for the next school year
well we want to make sure our kids are
cared for at school we all deserve to be
safe at home and at work and in our
neighborhoods no exceptions
that's why i want to talk next about
something every nevadan is concerned
about
we've seen cry crime rise
we've seen crime rates rise across the
country and here at home whether it's a
44 increase in homicides just last year
in clark county or an increase in
robberies in reno it's unacceptable here
are some things we are doing to turn
things around
we ban bump stocks close the gun show
loophole and now require common sense
background checks on all gun sales
we secured nearly 12 million dollars in
federal funding to recruit more officers
prevent youth crime and more
and under my administration the
percentage of our state budget devoted
to law enforcement is number one in the
country but there are still some big
holes we need to fill for example
our state police make less than most
municipal officers and as a result we
have a shortage of state police
if you're someone who is interested in
law enforcement career go to dps.nv.gov
because we need you and here's my
promise back when the legislature
returns to carson city i will be
proposing a salary increase so we
guarantee that nevada state police are
well trained and well paid
and as we work at the state level we
need our local law enforcement agencies
to evaluate the crime fighting programs
that they have
while our courts and prosecutors helped
determine the best way to reduce crime
in their communities
i have always supported increases in
funding for our police to make sure they
have the resources and training to
protect and respect the communities they
serve
as governor i will continue to partner
with anyone and everyone democrat
republican independent to make our
communities safe and to make sure our
police have the support they need
i've talked about a lot of issues today
safety in our community the cost of
living health care and education
but the truth is a vibrant growing
economy with good paying jobs goes a
long way towards solving many of these
challenges that's why i've been working
to build a stronger and more diverse
economic foundation for nevada to help
create an economy that works for you and
for nevada families
this stadium is an example of just that
it created thousands of new jobs from
construction to transportation from
small business suppliers to technical
staff from the tax dollars it generates
to the hotel rooms that it fills
this building represents one
just one part of a more diversified
economic future and we're building it
together
last year alone nevada added over 94 000
jobs to our economy we've been rated the
state with the best economic momentum in
the country
over a hundred startups launched in reno
in the last two years alone and yes
tourism is back hotel revenue is up and
our newly expanded las vegas convention
center is getting booked
that means jobs for our workers and tax
revenue for our state
this didn't happen by accident during
the pandemic we did everything we could
to keep small businesses open to attract
new companies to the state and support
our workers
in december i hosted job fest which was
attended by 2100 nevadans 182 employers
hired 251 attendees all in just one day
and those jobs just aren't statistics
they're people like the woman who came
up to me after being unemployed for
months she got hired on the spot and
that day her life and her family's life
changed when she cried and hugged me it
proved again what a good job means in a
person's life
another huge economic growth opportunity
for us is clean energy
with more sunshine than just about any
state in the nation nevada is on the way
to becoming the leading clean energy
economy in america
last year alone we saw the launch of
five new solar plants increasing our
state's solar capacity by 36 percent and
now nevada is ranked number one for
solar in the country renewable energy
tax abatements have created twelve
thousand construction in five thousand
operational jobs with an average wage of
more than 40 dollars an hour
we're investing in things like clean
energy school buses which will be funded
in part by fines on corporate polluters
these aren't just good jobs they're
critical jobs and critical tools in the
fight against climate change from the
day i took office i've worked to make
sure nevada is resilient as it tackles
this serious threat
today we're monitoring our carbon
footprint we're investing in
transportation electrification across
nevada we're implementing a plan to
ensure that 50 of nevada's energy comes
from clean energy by 2030 with net zero
greenhouse gases by 2050
but we can and we must do more climate
change puts us all at risk drought
wildfire lake mead's record low it
affects us every day extreme heat is
another one that's why this year i'll
convene members of my cabinet scientists
and climate leaders to create a
statewide strategy for dealing with
extreme heat we will continue leading
the fight against climate change and
creating good paying jobs in the process
because a resilient clean energy economy
is part of a strong diversified economy
let's not forget the essential role that
small business plays in our community i
know something about this i was a small
business owner myself and i face the
struggle that comes with starting a
business praying that your idea will be
successful was on one of the most
terrifying and most exciting periods of
my life
nevada business owners deserve a
government that has invested in their
success and stays out of their way
that's why i stopped any increase in
unemployment insurance taxes in 2022.
that's why we distributed 100 million
dollars to thousands of organizations
and small businesses to keep them going
during the pandemic
and why have worked to reduce
unnecessary regulation for example today
i'm announcing a bipartisan task force
the further reduced barriers when it
comes to occupational licensing here in
nevada we license everyone from barbers
to private investigators and the system
needs to change i'm also creating the
first ever nevada small business
accelerator program to help new startups
get off the ground and expand putting
nevada at the forefront of emerging
technologies
and one more thing to make sure more
money drops to the bottom line i will
keep nevada a low tax state the fact is
as we work to grow the economy we need
roads bridges and highways to move
materials and create jobs
the good news is that today we're
actually ranked number one of all states
in infrastructure and we're in the top
10 for our roads and highways that's
real progress
but we're about to make another leap
forward using dollars from the federal
bipartisan infrastructure bill i support
that i support it and our federal
delegation delivered to us
we will invest 4 billion dollars to
upgrade our roads our bridges and our
water system
over 500 million dollars for new
broadband infrastructure to make sure
every nevadan has access to high-speed
internet
big new improvements at our airports in
our public transportation systems and
over eight million dollars to try and
get our hands around wildfire prevention
these investments overwhelmingly
supported by democrats republicans and
independents will create thousands of
new union jobs and are the building
blocks of an even stronger economy
as we continue to move forward we need
to make sure no nevadan gets left behind
i've always believed that the key to a
good job doesn't always have to run
through the gates of a four-year college
that's why i've worked to create new
career and technical training
opportunities for students and those
looking for retraining
we've already expanded stem education
and apprenticeship programs with over 30
000 students completing training since i
took office
we've created new opportunities for over
ten thousand high school students to
begin earning their associate's degree
while finishing their high school
diploma
and last but certainly not least we know
that skills training is essential to our
workers and our businesses a high school
education isn't enough and we should
know we should recognize that it's no
longer preschool through grade 12 but at
least preschool through community
college or other post high school
training
for that reason i'm directing my
workforce development committee to
explore ways to make community college
or other apprentice and training
programs free for more nevadans by 2025.
i know we can get it done
nevada i have never been more optimistic
about our state or where we're going
despite two difficult years that have
changed everyone and challenged every
one of us again and again i've seen
incredible acts of kindness heroic acts
of selflessness and determination to
never stop moving forward
family has never been more important and
no no that's true for me as i look over
my wife kathy and my daughters ashley
and carly
ultimately this is about making life
better for the people we love
i think that's true for all of us when
we get up each day to go to our jobs
provide for our kids try to make budgets
work or care for a parent we're
believers we believe that problems can
be solved that big things can be
accomplished whether it's a stadium that
unites us a new job that excites us or
classroom that ignites something special
in a young child we're united in our
determination
as i said in my opening getting things
done always works best when we come
together when we put aside party labels
put down our heads and get to work
that's the true battleborn spirit that
has propelled our state forward for the
last 157 years
it is what i try to do every day as your
governor and with your help it's what
will build an even stronger nevada
thank you